most of you probably know or seen
the news about my wife i'm not sure if
you guys seen
but she's okay
she's good
she's strong
that's justin bieber praising his wife
haley at his show last week following
her hospitalization for a blood clot and
now a source is telling e.t how the
health scare has elevated the couple's
marriage
[Music]
source says haley went through a
traumatic experience with her blood clot
but she is doing much better and is
healthy and despite it being traumatic
this solidified that justin will always
be by her side through thick and thin
and make sure she is taken care of and
supported in any capacity he's just
really sweet earlier this month haley
revealed her hospitalization on
instagram sharing quote i started having
stroke-like symptoms and was taken to
the hospital they found i had suffered a
very small blood clot to my brain which
caused a small lack of oxygen but my
body had passed it on its own and i
recovered completely within a few hours
the 25 year old model describes the
experience as definitely one of the
scariest moments she's ever been through
and turns out it was a frightening time
for justin too you know it's kind of
crazy how life randomly throws you
curveballs you know we can't really
can't really control much most of you
probably know or seen
the news about my wife i'm not sure if
you guys seen
but she's okay
she's good
she's strong
but it's been scary you know like it's
been really scary
and that scary moment turned into an
important realization in their
relationship our source says although
the 28 year old singer was shaken up by
the experience haley knows now more than
ever that she can always rely and lean
on him when she needs support haley is
his world and he can never imagine life
without her this brought them closer
together than ever before and it was a
reminder for both of them to really
appreciate each other and their special
relationship i know for a fact
that god has her in the palm of his
hands
it's an amazing feeling and there's no
doubt the biebers are looking forward to
their future together which involves
babies
[Music]
just last month a source told e.t haley
and justin believe a big family is in
their destiny i'm excited adding the
couple both know what great parents they
are going to be together they both feel
like part of their reason for being on
earth was to be parents it has been
instilled in them since day one and they
are looking forward to making that
happen
[Music]